estas dos cantidades contienen el dígito
4 aquí está en 1 y aquí está en el otro
queremos comparar el valor de ambos
dígitos según su posición los invito a
que pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo por su cuenta
veamos estos cuatros este primer 4 de
acá que representa bueno estamos aquí en
las unidades aquí están las escenas y
aquí están las centenas así que este 4
es un 400 4% igual a 400 ahora veamos la
otra cantidad estamos aquí unidades
decenas centenas millares este 4 está en
los millares por lo que su valor por
posiciones 4 por mil igual a 4000 ahora
podemos compararlos en el primer 4 es 10
veces más pequeño que el segundo 4 lo
que tiene mucho sentido pues este primer
4 está un lugar a la derecha del segundo
este está en 123 con la cuarta posición
1 2
34 s está en la tercera posición y cada
que nos movemos un lugar hacia la
derecha de la posición se decremento en
un factor de 10 así que el valor del 4
en esta cantidad
es una décima parte del valor del 4 en
esta otra cantidad